[Música]
a ideia que o script passar hoje equipe
uma aproximação e uma interação entre a
ciência selado por trazer benefícios
muito grandes para ambas as partes e
espero convencer o egito
a ciência é base é fonte do conhecimento
é base do desenvolvimento econômico traz
nos também muita esperança na área da
saúde porque possibilita todos os
progressos que temos vindo a verificar
ao longo dos tempos quer nos melhores
tratamentos em à prevenção e ao
diagnóstico e muitas vezes na cura de
doenças que nos afetam a todos por outro
lado a senado civil tem tido também um
papel muito importante no progresso da
investigação científica que através de
chamada ciência participativa em coxilha
dá uns podem colaborar com os
investigadores na recolha de dados para
projectos de investigação isso acontece
muito em projetos de ecologia que é
também quando é será que se viu e já
acontece né com algumas acontece com
algumas exceções doença em várias partes
do mundo que elas contribuem ao
sugerirem temas do interesse dos doentes
por outro lado a sociedade civil tem
também um papel muito importante tem
tido um papel em um contributo
importante no financiamento da
investigação científica e sobre este
financiamento privado da ciência e que
envolve iniciativas na sear civil que eu
quero falar porque este também a área à
qual a qual tenho dedicado e queremos
falar deste financiamento como uma forma
de investimento com retorno para para
ambas as partes e para isso vou dar um
exemplo dois institutos de investigação
fizeram também parte do meu percurso um
deus é o blog sofresse cáceres center um
centro de investigação em londres onde
eu fiz investigação durante alguns anos
na área do cancro da mama e foi aqui que
eu realmente percebi o impacto que esse
lado civil potter no progresso da
investigação neste caso no instituto de
investigação para vos dar o exemplo este
instituto angariava mais 20 milhões de
libras por ano é iniciativas na
sociedade civil e quando falo em
iniciativas da sociedade civil falou
caminhadas de corridas de torneios de
parcerias com empresas e muitas outras
ações que eram organizadas na sociedade
civil e nós como investigadores do
instituto participávamos também nestas
iniciativas que eram feitas na sociedade
civil
por outro lado tenhamos também
frequentemente vidas de no instituto
visitas semanais e obviamente de uma
forma rotativa pessoas individuais de
sessões do doente de doentes que criam
conhecer mais sobre os projectos de
investigação que também ajudava a
financiar e criam também visitar os
laboratórios queriam conhecer os
cientistas e foi por isso que uma parte
da empresa área e que se vicri de khar
na área das iniciativas da sociedade
civil é e que resolvi fazer este
trabalho mas queria fazê-lo em portugal
porque é uma cultura que ainda não
estava enraizada no nosso país e por
isso consegui sair é um instituto ao
instituto gulbenkian de ciência em
oeiras onde também já tinha feito a
parte curricular do meu doutoramento no
instituto gulbenkian de ciência o
instituto de investigação de influência
a nível internacional que também já tem
muitas vezes filantrópicas e não sair se
conhecem o igc é que foi fundado há já
mais de 50 anos por usar este comentário
de carlos colman que não foi fundado por
fundação calouste gulbenkian mas porque
calouste gulbenkien tem a noção da
importância que a investigação
científica podia ter para o
desenvolvimento do país então tinha
também uma grande paixão possível se
eles têm muito importante ea paixão pela
ciência como vocês sabem também por usar
sua música pintura e foi por isso que o
deixou em testamento parte da sua
fortuna era para investir em ciência foi
por isso que construiu esse instituto
que tanto tem contribuído para o
progresso da investigação científica
foi também aqui não existe e que iniciou
a maratona de saúde de povos vou falar
mais à frente mas para já me falaram
isso algumas iniciativas que ajuda a
desenvolver quando regressei a portugal
e quando queria muito é continua a
querer fazer estas ações
uma delas é é uma uma parceria que deixa
muito orgulhosa que foi
foi anunciada logo em 2008 quando
regressei a portugal que foi a parceria
entre o instituto gulbenkian de ciência
e eles ingleses mil a r 100 mil é
promotora do festival nós live e
permitiu ao instituto convém eficiência
ter um espaço ao lado de grandes marcas
para fazer para fazer a sensibilização
de ciência uma das iniciativas com mais
sucesso no âmbito desta parceria foi o
speedy item confiantes da vitória visar
exemplo - dois investigadores do
instituto resolveram iniciar os seus
doutoramentos ano no instituto
gulbenkian de ciência porque fizeram os
pedais tem conheceram outros cientistas
durante este val por outro lado e também
muito importante na área na direção de
fundos e vice em 2000 foi lance ia por
ano duas bolsas de investigação jovens
recém-licenciados e já possibilitou ao
longo destes mais de dez anos parceria
que 18 jovens pudessem iniciar as suas
carreiras de investigação no instituto
gulbenkian de ciência e também em
parceria com outras instituições
estrangeiras
é por isso uma parceria que foi
continuar a ser inédita quer a nível
nacional quer a nível internacional e
tem sido publicada com ipos como ouvir
música é final também dá futuro mesmo
que eu acredito que música era futuro
puro por si só é outras duas iniciativas
foram desenvolvidas com o mesmo objetivo
o objetivo é despertar a curiosidade
para temas ciência foi a coleção de
eficiência do do igc que utilizou
imagens que eram obtidas durante os
trabalhos de alguns dos investigadores
do instituto bem com eficiência e parte
das vendas desta coleção revertem para a
investigação científica que é
desenvolvida no instituto
outra iniciativa foi desenvolvida em
conjunto com duas amigas e também
colegas né na área
na área da comunicação deficiência foi a
coleção de chats views on fire foi
desenvolvida é só pra dizer os nomes
porque o chão aqui do porto com essa era
o chicão é filme e claro
josé castro e daí era também utilizar
motivos de ciência para disputar esta
tal curiosidade em 2012 na china então é
a maratona eu sou da maratona de saúde
foi um sonho tornado realidade é uma
cisão sem fins lucrativos foi fundada no
ano em que portugal também atravessava
uma grave crise econômica foi fundada em
conjunto com os fios rodrix também tá é
que presente que eu não consigo ver com
com essas lutas e foi fundada também
pelo professor antônio coutinho que foi
o principal mentor desta iniciativa no
nosso país xi que foi também o primeiro
presidente a maratona da saúde é este
projecto pretendeu implementar em
portugal um formato de sucesso a nível
internacional que é o chamado teleton
eletron significa que o virgem maratona
não é uma corrida não é uma caminhada
mas é uma maratona televisiva de muitas
horas consecutivas e em directo em que
se pretende aliar à informação e ao
entretenimento e desta forma é fazermos
sensibilização nas áreas da ciência e da
saúde
ao mesmo tempo entendemos também
angariar fundos durante o espetáculo
para podermos apoiar a investigação
científica para vos dar e como exemplo o
teleton que aconteça em países como
frança e itália também espanha na
catalunha engenharia milhões de euros
por ano para apoiar a investigação na
área da saúde e algumas doenças nesses
países e já é uma das principais fontes
de financiamento da ciência em portugal
estamos temos parceria com a rtp rtp o
nosso parceiro mídia enfim a rtp não
teria sido possível esta maratona
televisiva no nosso peniche a maratona
do sul e vai já na cct medição esta
edição que começou há muito pouco tempo
esta servicar as doenças raras e vai ter
lugar até junho do próximo ano
já fizemos 16 espetáculos solidários na
rtp dedicados a outras doenças e eu
queria mostrar dos algumas das
fotografias deste dia anual solidário
da maratona da saúde na rtp que é
apresentado por várias caras conhecidas
embaixo tem fotografias do espetáculo
solidário da edição passada foi dedicada
ao cancro e que foi transmitido em
direto dos estúdios da rtp em vila nova
de gaia contou com muito apoio local de
muitas das sessões doentes de pessoas
individuais que vieram juntar médicos
cientistas e também figuras públicas e e
artistas
todas as exibições nós convidamos para
além de muitos outros artistas 18 estava
turban na para nos ajudar é ter uma
perspectiva de frente de sistemas e
também para conseguirmos chegar a outros
públicos
muito importante também na maratona da
saúde é o nosso call center
o nosso call center é seguido pela
fundação altis portugal também está com
a maratona da saúde desde o início e
permite-nos e tal agressão de fundos
através de chamadas telefônicas podem
ser chamadas telefônicas para o concerto
podem ser de portugal ou do estrangeiro
e também as pessoas podem também fazer
donativos através de uma linha de valor
acrescentado ao que temos ativa durante
todo o ano mas que obviamente neste dia
solidário é mais usada para donativos a
maratona da saúde
muito importante também para não acham
os novos testemunhos nosso testemunho no
chão os nossos embaixadores da nosa
motivação para continuarmos a acreditar
na esperança que a investigação
biomédica nos dá e criarmos o falar-vos
da conceição diz que está aqui numa
fotografia com os feridos à direita num
programa de rádio da maratona de saúde
conceição mora aqui e do porto mora em
vila nova de gaia há muitos muitos anos
e tem sido incansável no seu apoio a
maratona foi nossa embaixadora
nas duas edições do caen que a concessão
já passou por dois cancros um estômago
depois outro é recentemente na mama e
continua com uma esperança imensa na
investigação é uma voluntária muito
ativa nesta área ajudou recentemente
criar a sessão caso é que tem sede no
hospital de santo antónio no porto que o
apoio a mulheres com cancro da mama
bem aos seus familiares a concessão
porque falou com investigadores também
durante a maratona da saúde resolveu
fazer um teste genético e descobriu
também que eu quero é hereditário os
resultados não vieram há tempo para
processar 1 prevenir o segundo cancro
que teve mas conseguiu ajudar familiares
muito próximos e faz também
sensibilização podem para a importância
da realização dos testes dos testes
genéticos para além da nossa maratona
televisiva são também organizadas várias
iniciativas ao longo do ano iniciativas
locais por todo o país
eu queria salvar o exemplo de algumas
iniciativas que foram organizadas a
equipe perto no porto e em vila nova de
gaia uma delas foi a parceria com as
escolas drogas fortes do futebol clube
do porto e tom a galeria boa que nos
produziu muitos corações em cerâmica
foram depois pintados todos a em zoom
pros meninos destas desta escola do
futebol clube do porto e que foram
também ajudaram também angaria fundos
para apoiar a maratona da saúde
tivemos também uma iniciativa do
desporto foi organizada por aqui de mil
mais que que em vila nova de gaia que
converteu também para a maratona da
saúde é grande porto é sermos também em
várias edições da maratona da saúde
inscrições solidárias para várias das
suas provas comissão é que as corridas
são silvestre do porto e braga e e as
inscrições as inscrições que vetem na
totalidade para a maratona do sul eu não
podia deixar de falar sobre os
investigadores também aqui do norte que
tem participado em todas as edições da
maratona da solução os influentes
embaixadores em especial os
investigadores do treze que têm sido
incansáveis o treze é também o instituto
de investigação de chuvas em portugal e
que está filiado aqui no porto e também
organiza muitas ações que são dirigidas
a ser a de civil
finalmente os prémios maratona da saúde
os prêmios maratona da saúde são a
cereja no topo do bolo da da maratona da
saúde são atribuídos anualmente com os
fundos angariados na sociedade civil
através de um concurso que é realizado
em parceria com a fundação para a
ciência e tecnologia am e tamos e tem
também o júri internacional isto é
importante estamos muito contentes
porque já financiamos 13 investigadores
que realizam seus trabalhos em várias
instituições do país de norte a sul
vamos financiar mais dois investigadores
na área do cancro muito em breve nos
próximos meses os nossos premiados estão
sempre disponíveis para darem a conhecer
os seus projectos acelerada civil que
tem participado em várias ações que são
organizadas plan maratona nesse nesse
sentido um exemplo são f.iniciativas
cientistas em turnê em que organizamos
seminários nas cidades um trabalho e
estes investigadores seminários que são
abertos a toda a comunidade e que são de
entrada livre
vamos também realizar muito em breve a
iniciativa encontra se expressa que foi
recentemente financiado e premiada por
ciência viva e pretende fomentar
encontros entre os nossos premiados e as
sessões doentes e doentes nos institutos
onde aos trabalhos esta iniciativa vai
ter também um canal aberto aberto todos
onde um canal online onde poderão fazer
perguntas aos nossos premiados saberem
mais sobre o sobre os projetos que estão
a desenvolver
só me resta agradecer vos eu espero ter
disputado um caminho a vossa curiosidade
para saberem mais sobre a investigação
que se faz em portugal para conhecerem
os nossos cientistas e também para
acompanhar e participar na maratona da
saúde muito obrigada também sempre
disponíveis para ajudar a responder às
vossas questões obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]